science maintenant une découverte qui va
tordre le cou à bien des idées reçues on
a isolé le gène de la féminité et les
spécialistes ont conclu contrairement à
bien des préceptes notamment théologique
et biblique que la femme est
rigoureusement l'égal de l'homme
une bonne nouvelle commenté par vincent
guerre et dieu créa l'homme à son image
pour lui donc des modèles abarth comme
celui là et après après seulement il
bricole à la femme avec un bout d'homme
certains modèles furent assez réussi cet
épisode de l'histoire de la création
remonte à trois mille ans environ la
femme était dans issus de l'homme issu
traduisait pas grand chose les grecs les
romains les juifs avaient la même idée
qui se fondait sur l'observation c'est
un être plus petit menu faible ici père
au combat et surtout c'est un gibier que
l'on chasse et bien la chasse est fermée
depuis quelques années on sait que
l'homme le mal peut se résumer par ces
deux chromosomes x et y
avant on savait que le gène sr y était
responsable de la masculinité maison
penser que l'absence de ce gène
suffisait à construire une femme
on était donc femme par défaut après la
découverte de ces chercheurs italiens ça
marche plus ils ont découvert un nouveau
gène le dss il est essentiel à la
masculinité lui aussi mais sa présence
en deux exemplaires abouti à la
construction d'une femme pas simple mais
important la femme a bien quelque chose
pour la construire d'ailleurs cela eût
été tout à fait invraisemblable qu'il
n'en soit pas ainsi parce que vous êtes
mesdames assez remarquable et complexe
il fallait bien qu'il y ait des jeunes
pour vous faire en voilà quelques-uns
professeur peut-on affirmer aujourd'hui
que la femme est l'égal de l'homme sur
un plan génétique grâce à cette
découverte
selon moi on pouvait la firme est déjà
auparavant mais votre complexité
génétique n'a rien à envier à la nôtre
voilà ce que l'on peut dire
jusqu'à cette découverte le néant
aujourd'hui existe donc une résistance
génétique féminine à la toute puissance
du gène masculin mais rassurez vous
messieurs un être humain compte cent
mille jeunes 5000 seulement sont connus
la femme ne vient donc de lever qu'un
tout petit coin du voile de son mystère